dennis mein fahrer gibt vollgas sein
vater hat angerufen
vor dem nachbarhaus sei gerade eine
granate explodiert
[Applaus]
mama ist tot
[Musik]
die hand ist kalt
das ist meine frau
sie hat immer so feine sachen gebacken
ständig war sie in der küche
sie war alleine zu hause
den ganzen morgen wurde geschossen sie
liebt es ist bis jetzt keine hilfe
gekommen die 63 jährige claudia eines
von tausenden von opfern des krieges in
der ost ukraine
das ist ihr handy ich will das nicht
[Musik]
vor einem jahr war für mich die ukraine
noch ein land der hoffnung
heute ist vieles anders wie erleben die
menschen in der ukraine den krieg in der
heimat
dieser frage will ich nachgehen die
ukrainische hauptstadt kiew im februar
die leichen getöteter demonstranten auf
dem majdan den zentralen platz der
unabhängigkeit
hier lerne ich alex sie kennen die alle
in diesem film nennen wir ihn zu seiner
sicherheit nur beim vornamen
er hatte gerade eine der leichen hierher
gebracht
[Musik]
er stand neben mir auf der barrikade
dann hat ein scharfschütze ihm in die
lunge geschossen
gerade erst vor zehn minuten als wir ihn
wegtrugen sagte er noch verdammt ich
will nicht sterben
[Musik]
drei monate zuvor
der damalige ukrainische präsident
viktor janukowitsch sagt die
europäischen union nein zu einem
freihandelsabkommen
er gibt damit dem druck von wladimir
putin der russische präsident hatte die
ukraine mit einer handelsblockade
gedroht
aber auch finanzhilfen in milliardenhöhe
versprochen auf den straßen kiews
verlangen hunderttausende dass die
ukraine auf ihrem europäischen kurs
bleibt unter ihnen viele studenten
unternehmer intellektuelle immer mehr
verlangen auch den rücktritt des
präsidenten janukowitsch
[Applaus]
dieser reagiert zunehmend mit
polizeigewalt
als folge davon versammeln sich radikale
demonstranten auf dem majdan unter ihnen
auch bewaffnete
[Musik]
am 18 februar beginnt die polizei mit
der räumung des platzes die situation
eskaliert zwei tage später schießen
scharfschützen auf die demonstranten
viele hintergründe sind noch unklar
aber die regierung steht am pranger
das ist kein bürgerkrieg wir schießen
nicht brüder auf brüder ihr tötet die
polizei ihre eignen würde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nach diesem drama beugt sich
janukowitsch dem internationalen druck
und er verspricht neuwahlen dann aber
flüchtete er nach russland
auf druck der strasse oder
fallengelassen von seinen
sicherheitskräften
diese frage bleibt offen jedenfalls soll
er noch viel geld und wertsachen
mitgenommen haben
das ukrainische parlament wählt
daraufhin eine übergangsregierung
spricht aber von einer faschistischen
runter und einem staatsstreich
[Musik]
in diesen tagen treffe ich alex ii
wieder eine letzte zigarette zur ehren
der über 100 menschen die auf dem majdan
ihr leben ließen
[Musik]
opfer für den vermeintlichen sieg des
magens
[Musik]
heute wissen wir es war nur der anfang
des ukrainischen dramas
nur wenige tage später schickt wladimir
putin seine soldaten auf die ukrainische
halbinsel krim
anfang mai wir sind unterwegs sind die
stadt tornetz im osten der ukraine die
metropole der sogenannten don't us
regierung einst sowjetische stolz und
hochburg der kohlebergwerke und der
schwerindustrie eine zeit der viele
menschen hier nachtrauern
bei filmaufnahmen am straßenrand
stürmten dein mann auf uns los er meint
zuerst wie er seinen vom ukrainischen
fernsehen schaut mit solchen waffen
werden wir jetzt unsere heimat
verteidigen
die unabhängige demokratische republik
dombach morgen ist das referendum
wir wollen hier alle eine ehrliche
unabhängige eigene republik zusammen mit
russland oder alleine
ich selber bin dafür dass wir uns
russland anschließen putin ist einfach
toll
er wird uns und ganz europa von der
faschistischen pest befreien
aber jetzt wollen sich hier alle
einmischen merkel mischt sich ein und
auch obama sie wollen uns in die knie
zwingen
niemand wird jemals den don bars in die
knie zwingen
dimitri verlangen in diesen tagen
tausende von menschen im osten die
abspaltung von der ukraine
es ist eigentlich eine minderheit wie
umfragen zeigen
dennoch ist sie sehr präsent alles wirkt
auf mich irgendwie orchestriert was ist
wunsch nach besserem leben was ist
russische propaganda für mich schwer
einzuschätzen
in den wochen davor hatten bewaffnete
separatisten im donbass
verwaltungsgebäude besetzt anhänger der
territorialen einheit der ukraine lebten
jetzt gefährlich
hunderte wurden entführt teils gefoltert
oder sogar ermordet
führende anführer der separatisten
kommen aus russland und russische
demonstranten kommen busweise in die
ukraine gewählte ukrainische politiker
müssen weichen
selbsternannte volkstribun oft mit
rechtsextremem hintergrund treten an
ihre stelle
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann tauchen paramilitärische truppen
mit schwerem kriegsgerät auf unter ihnen
ehemalige spezialeinsatzkräfte vom ex
präsident janukowitsch aber auch viele
russen und türken
am 11 mai das referendum über die
unabhängigkeit der region donetsk und
lugansk die stimmen zählen die
separatisten selber eine farce das
massive jahr wird weder von kiew noch
international anerkannt
[Musik]
die ukrainische übergangsregierung
schickt die armee in den bars diese ist
in einem desolaten zustand
im umgang mit ihren prorussischen
landsleuten sind die kurzfristig
aufgebotenen soldaten überfordert
wie schlecht es um die armee im mai
steht muss ich selber miterleben
[Musik]
nahe der kleinstadt wollen wacher in der
donezker region treffen wir auf völlig
verstörte ukrainische soldaten in den
frühen morgenstunden haben pro-russische
separatisten hier über ein dutzend
soldaten überfallen und ermordet
die überlebenden soldaten forderten
danach luftunterstützung an
diese kam nicht nur zu spät wie
filmaufnahmen eines soldaten zeigen
schossen die ukrainische hubschrauber
auf die eigenen kämpfer ein
sinnbildliche scouts das sind helikopter
die auf unsere straßensperre schießen
dort wo die leichen liegen ich kann
nicht sagen ob das unsere sind oder
nicht das war die stunde der
ukrainischen freiwilligen bataillone
verbände nationalistischer kämpfer von
denen viele schon ihren durchhaltewillen
auf dem majdan gezeigt hatten hier und
treffe ich alex ii wieder der
familienvater und kleinunternehmer ist
aus seiner heimatstadt new orleans
gereist die über 1000 kilometer westlich
an der polnischen grenze liegt
der instruktor ein afghanistan veteran
erklärt wie man scharfschützen beseitigt
vielleicht sitzt der scharfschütze in
einem kindergarten wo es noch kinder und
erwachsene gibt dann überlegt euch nicht
zehn mann einzusetzen und ihnen da sogar
noch lieben da rauszuholen
nehmt einen minenwerfern schieß los und
macht diesen kerlen fertig so ist der
krieg ihr könnt nicht den weißen
handschuhen für ordnung sorgen
es ist ein bunter haufen den wir treffen
überzeugte patrioten aber auch
rechtsradikale und ausländische söldner
die regierung in kiew nimmt dies in kauf
für sie gilt wer bereit ist für die
front der ist willkommen
alexei war in verschiedenen
kampfverbänden mit dem neo nazis sagte
er habe überhaupt nichts zu tun
seine beiden großväter hätten gegen
hitler deutschland gekämpft
[Musik]
die menschen im osten nehmen diese
vermeintlichen befreie aber häufig als
besitzer war das ist eigentlich ein
informationskrieg und diesen
informationskrieg hat die ukraine
verloren
man hätte die russischen fernsehkanäle
schon von anfang an verbieten sollen
oder sie vor gericht ziehen wegen nicht
objektiver berichterstattung
darum gibt es jetzt eine generation von
leuten die ihre ukrainischen mitbürger
hassen ihnen hatte man zb eingetrichtert
sie dürfen kein russisch mehr sondern
nur ukrainisch sprechen was schlicht
nicht stimmt ich spreche ja selbst nur
russisch
alexei hat daheim ein kleines lastwagen
unternehmen sein zwillingsbruder oleg
vertritt ihn dort war aber dennoch muss
er von der front ausständig mithelfen
er verdiene nichts als freiwilliger sagt
ollek sie mir es gibt aber bataillone
die von ukrainischen oligarchen
finanziert werden
viele kämpfer hatten vor ihrem einsatz
keine militärische erfahrung wie schnell
die länge du zählst desto schwieriger
wird es
der nächste kampf kann jede minute
losgehen
sie können jederzeit anrufen und sagen
ab in den kampf und dann geht es los
[Musik]
die stimmung bei den kämpfern ist gut es
ist juni die ukraine stehen vor der
einnahme von donetsk
im august wird die ukrainische offensive
dann aber jäh gestoppt
höchstwahrscheinlich durch einen
großeinsatz russischer soldaten der
kreml bestreitet dies
[Musik]
ich fahre von donetsk nach slawinski die
stadt war im frühling hochburg der
separatisten
jetzt ist sie wieder in ukrainischer
hand
[Musik]
viele menschen hatten hier eine
annäherung an russland befürwortet aber
den pro-russischen separatisten weinen
sie keine träne nach stabilität und
sicherheit ist ihr größter wunsch
[Musik]
der alltag wieder und der ukrainische
führung ist friedlich im krassen
gegensatz zu den erfundenen
horrormeldungen die das russische
staatsfernsehen verbreitet hatte darin
hieß es hier sei ein kleinkind
öffentlich gekreuzigt worden
real es dieses ereignis auf das sich
hier zufällig dose ein massengrab wird
ausgehoben
die separatisten haben hier die leichen
ihrer kämpfer verschachert aber es
finden sich auch die überreste
ukrainische bürger und aktivisten
ermordet
manche gefoltert
ein schon familie hatte eine schlägerei
die separatisten nahmen ihn dann einfach
mit und erschossen ihn
[Musik]
es ist herbst den dollars
offiziell herrscht seit einem monat
waffenstillstand doch wie in anderen
städten kommt es auch internets immer
wieder zu artilleriegefechte geschosse
landen in wohngebieten unschuldige
menschen sterben
wenn ich nach den schuldigen frage höre
ich fast immer die gleiche antwort
ich bin nicht ganz sicher wer und
beschossen hat aber ich gehe davon aus
das ist unsere ukrainische armee war sie
haben doch solche waschen wenn ich
jünger wäre würde ich mich den
pro-russischen separatisten anschließen
das ist vladimir ein bauarbeiter und
bewohner eines tun ätzte außenbezirke
auf seinem hausdach zählte die sekunden
zwischen abschuss und ein schlag von
artilleriegranaten hast du gehört diese
granate klingt wie schotter den mann
ausschüttet wladimir will uns die krater
der gestrigen granatenexplosionen zeigen
siehst du hier hinten sieht man
überhaupt keine spuren von
granatsplitter das geschoss kam von
dieser seite
und da hinten siehst du wo die später
angeschlagen sind
nein die ukraine haben die chance
nochmal ich stehe hier im krater
die granate kam aus dieser richtung und
dort sind die prorussischen separatisten
wladimir zeigt uns wo die kaserne der
separatisten ist die separatisten
schießen hier von unserem dorf aus auf
die ukraine ich kann euch genau zeigen
wo ihre artillerie ist hier die gasse
herunter durchstehen zweistöckige
baracken
man sollte den verbrannten baum blätter
von wo aus sie schießen der nachbar war
vladimir er solle aufpassen es sei den
separatisten in der nähe
laut internationalen beobachtern waren
es mehrheitlich die prorussischen
separatisten die den waffenstillstand
seit september gebrochen haben aber
beide seiten werden scharf kritisiert
für den hochgefährlichen einsatz von
artillerie waffen in wohngebieten
wladimir ist auf beide parteien böse
früher hatte ich den ganzen zaun im
ukrainischen blau gelb ich war richtiger
patriot aber das ist vorbei jetzt schäme
ich mich dafür ukraine zu sein
wir haben einen präsidenten der nicht im
stande ist den krieg zu beenden
ich bin einfach slave ein mensch ohne
nationalität am vorabend explodierten
mehrere granaten in der nachbarschaft
vladimir brachte seine frau und die
kinder in den keller
sie waren schon unten und meine frau
schreit ich solle sofort die lücke
schließen
ich sagte ihr für was dann kommen wir
vielleicht nicht mehr raus wenn es eine
explosion gibt müssen wir hoffen dass
der boden hält dann schloss sich die
lupe ein wenig höhere die explosion vor
dem fenster und schon kamen die
glasscherben angeflogen
hier oben hat mein sohn geschlafen dort
die mädchen hier auf diesen matratzen
war meine frau
nicht nur einen großen nahrungsmittel
vorrat hat wladimir im keller angelegt
auch das internet soll hier
funktionieren
ich sagte zu meiner frau wenn
irgendetwas passiert hast du vielleicht
noch über internet kontakt zum
einschlafen hatte ich den kindern noch
trickfilme gezeigt ich sage ihnen nicht
was tatsächlich los ist sie meinen es
sei nur ein spiel
das ist besser so damit sie kein trauma
davon tragen von der druckwelle als die
knöpfe raus gehören uns zeigen sie hier
nur mehr russische programm das ist der
separatisten kanal
das wäre der ukrainische nichts zu sehen
ukrainische nachrichten kann ich nur
über das internet empfangen
hier der erste russische kammer ich
schaue nachrichten und dort sagt der
reporter live aus donetsk die ukraine
beschießen das stadtzentrum
dann höre ich hier wie die separatisten
dreimal granaten abfeuern
wenige sekunden später höre ich diese
drei schüsse live im fernsehen und die
behauptung es wären die ukraine gewesen
und wer hat tatsächlich geschossen
die separatisten nicht die ukraine
wladimir hat seine familie in sicherheit
gebracht ehe muss weiterhin in donetsk
geld verdienen
gelegenheitsjobs
seit einem jahr ist feste arbeit selten
sergej ein unternehmer sieht schwarz für
die wirtschaft die separatisten gebiet
mit dem ersten tag ihrer machtergreifung
ist hier alles kaputt gegangen unter
denen gibt es keine zukunft
wir menschen hier im donbass sind
inzwischen geiseln geworden
die ukrainische regierung trägt die
schuld aber auch russland das sich hier
einmischt es heißt sie bringen
baumaterial aus russland ich habe noch
nicht ein einziges haus gesehen dass sie
repariert ich denke sie bringen mit
diesen humanitären transporte vor allem
waffen aus russland und munition nach
jedem konvoi nimmt die kriegerische
auseinandersetzung wieder zu
donezk anfang november
[Musik]
die prorussischen separatisten
beherrschen nach wie vor die stadt
symbole eines vermeintlich neuen staates
tunnels an diesem wochenende wollen sie
ein neues staatsoberhaupt wählen lassen
am vortag der wahl ein sowjetischer
subotnick ein samstag fürs gemeinwohl
aber tatsächlich ein show anlass der
rebellenführer für kiew ist dies ein
illegaler akt aber auch für den westen
und den damaligen schweizer osze
präsidenten didier burkhalter den
mitbegründer der donetsk republik andrej
borodin beeindruckt das kaum
die schweiz ist auch ein land das sich
seiner demokratischen traditionen
berühmt und dies in der ganzen welt
weitergeben wer jetzt kommen sie hierher
und sagen waren seien etwas schlechtes
denken sie doch darüber nochmal bürger
der stadt sind dem aufruf zum subotnick
kaum gefolgt uns fällt aber eine junge
frau auf die motiviert hand anlegt
ich habe im internet gelesen dass sie
freiwillige suchen die hier mitarbeiten
und ich sagte mir warum nicht mithelfen
ich dachte aber erst kam eher
gewöhnliche leute so wie ich das hier
wohnt vorübergehend mit sohn und eltern
in einer mietwohnung im zentrum von
donetsk in ihre wohnung näher beim
umkämpften flughafen war es zu
gefährlich für artilleriefeuer hat sie
inzwischen ein feines ohr haben sie die
bombardierungen gehört das kommt von
dahinten das war wahrscheinlich eine
haubitze die schießen einzel feuer bei
den mehrfach raketenwerfern knallt es so
sechs bis achtmal hintereinander und die
sind auch lauter
mit ihrem sohn mit jahr war anastasia
zwischendurch bei verwandten in russland
danach versuchte sie in die ukrainische
stadt krakau fuß zu fassen
aber als familie aus donetsk seien sie
und sogar ihr sohn oft angefeindet
worden erzählt sie uns
wir sind im zentralen sportpalast für
gymnastik von donetsk
alle ukrainischen symbole und fahnen
sind verschwunden
aber ansonsten versuchen hier die
trainer normalität zu leben
dem kleinen mädchen gefällt
unser trainer heißt alexander
nikolajewitsch er ist ein sehr guter
sportler aber vor allem ein
hervorragender mensch mit den kindern
kann es ausgezeichnet
[Musik]
das training kein einziges mal abgesagt
auch dann nicht als fast keine kinder
mehr kommen konnten
für mich ist er ein held von der netz
[Musik]
der wunsch nach helden hier im donbass
ist er bis heute geblieben
dort wo einst die minen und
metallarbeiter helden für das ganze
sowjet volk warm
[Musik]
und auch am wahlsonntag ist vieles wie
zu sowjetzeiten angelockt werden die
menschen mit musik billigen kartoffeln
kohl und zwiebeln und drinnen finden
sich wahllisten ohne echte alternativen
zur auswahl stehen nämlich nur
separatisten
es lebe die donezker volksrepublik korea
genossen
ich fahre ganz in den westen der ukraine
mein ziel die stadt new orleans nach der
grenze zu polen
die derzeitige wirtschaftskrise lastet
schwer auf den menschen
aber arbeit fahren dieser region immer
schon knapp viele menschen gehen als
gastarbeiter nach polen oder in andere
europäische länder
die annäherung an die eu sehen sie als
chance die meisten sprechen ihr
ukrainisch moskau gegenüber sind viele
seit jeher kritisch eingestellt
[Musik]
eigentlich herrscht hier frieden der
donbass und der krieg sind über tausend
kilometer entfernt
aber immer neuer porträts von gefallenen
soldaten erinnern daran dass der
konflikt trauer und leid bis in die
letzten winkel der ukraine trägt diese
frau hat ihren sohn verloren er war als
polizist in dombach ist ein foto es in
der stadt gefallen
für die unabhängigkeit der ukraine aber
niemand kann mir sagen was genau
passiert ist
auch wenn es vielleicht furchtbar ist
ich möchte es unbedingt wissen die
kleinstadt nova linz ist die heimat von
alexei den freiwilligen kämpfer der nach
monaten an der front dem dollars wieder
einmal heim kommt
[Musik]
valencia
wir wissen dass seine frau olga arbeitet
vollzeitlich und kümmert sich um die
zwei töchter
hier habe ich medikamente
zwillingsbruder rolle hatte sich in den
letzten monaten um alexis transportfirma
gekümmert
[Musik]
das war bei röhrnbach
die separatisten waren wir
patrouillierten und wir mussten uns aus
dem hinterhalt befreien
[Musik]
was mich persönlich beleidigt ist dass
viele sagen das ist nicht mein krieg
sie sagen sie seien mir auch nicht auf
dem majdan gewesen
sie trinken ein wort zu ehren der
ukraine und dann hat es sich echte
patrioten müssen jetzt aktiv sein
es gibt solche die sagen ich kämpfe dann
wenn sie uns hier angreifen
aber dann wird es zu spät sein für den
kampf mit einem anti putin liter und
zwillingsbruder oleg geht zur
gesangsstunde der jüngeren tochter
es ist das erste mal überhaupt dass
alexy sie begleiten kann
[Musik]
warum
sind
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
zurückgekehrt ist sie auch für die
ukrainischen parlamentswahlen seit
jahren sitzt er bereits im stadtrat von
novell inc
jetzt möchte er seinen status als
kämpfer nutzen um ins nationale
parlament zu kommen
den wahlkampf managt allerdings
zwillingsbruder oleg er ersetzt alexy
zwischendurch sogar bei dessen wahl
auftritten
ich gehe hin und gebe mich als alex ii
aus vielleicht ist das rechtlich nicht
ganz aus
zudem haben wir natürlich einen
unterschiedlichen charakter aber
politisch decken sich unsere meinungen
und wir verfolgen beide die gleichen
ziele
das ziel eine starke ukraine ohne
größeren einfluss
die ukraine ist nicht groß aber wir sind
auch nicht europa wir müssen einfach
jetzt als nation entstehen uns als
ukrainische nation bilder und festigen
und wenn wir das schaffen können wir
entscheiden wie weiter an den
parlamentswahlen erhalten die radikale
nationalisten weniger stimmen als
erwartet
auch alex ii schafft es nicht nicht nur
er zweifelt ob dieses neue parlament die
wichtigen reformen schaffen wird gewählt
werden viele bisherige köpfe wie julia
timoschenko die pro europäischen
parteien mit vitali klitschko aber auch
nationalisten und im osten des landes
eine pro-russische partei eine spaltung
des landes wie eh und je
wir führen derzeit krieg gegen einen
äußeren feind gegen den wir uns
verteidigen müssen aber es gibt auch
einen inneren feind und gegen diesen wie
ich weiter kämpfen
ich meine unsere regierung und die
korrupten beamten die das land seit
jahren beraube leute wie olics sie
könnten auch für präsident petro
poroschenko früher oder später zur
bedrohung werden bevor beide brüder
zusammen wieder an die front fahren
besuchen sie noch einen befreundeten
rentner
der hat seit monaten nahrungsmittel
gesammelt alles für die fans alles für
den sieg
ruhm der ukraine
[Musik]
wir fahren wieder nach tunis es ist
mitte januar geworden
hillary krater und intensives
raketenfeuer schon vor der stadt
die straßen oft menschenleer
wir sind in einem wohngebiet nahe des
umkämpften ölhafens haben sie mich
erschreckt ich dachte sie hätten ein
gewehr in der hand berührt wieso gehen
sie nicht von hier weg wir können
nirgendwo sonst hin
wir haben kein geld aber immerhin haben
wir einen guten warmen keller die
enkelkinder sind seit tagen dort der
ältere ist zwölf jahre das baby zehn
monate es gibt fast keine sicheren orte
mehr in der stadt und ihr steht auch
hier herum hancock und dabei wert
feiertag aber nicht mal dann hören sie
auf alles gute
alles gute
frische krater nach einem
artilleriebeschuss
die fenster sind bei der explosion
kaputt gegangen so leben wir kein wasser
kein licht nicht guten tag babuschka wie
geht es ihnen
lustig lustig haben wir es sie die sich
in galgenhumor flüchtete sammelt schnee
um wenigstens wasser für die toilette zu
haben wozu aufräumen sollen sie nur
sehen wie wir uns hier wärmen müssen die
ganzen ersparnisse sind weg sogar die
vom kinde konto niemand hilft mir
wir brauchen nur noch frieden frieden
dann müssen wir dringend weg
unsere fahrer will nicht mehr länger auf
uns warten
sie fangen an von dort zurück zu
schießen
wir müssen schleunigst weg ich konnte
euch doch nicht alleine lassen wir
fahren zurück ins zentrum von donezk
aber auch hier ist es nicht mehr sicher
zwei geschosse minen wie man uns sagt
sind vor einem krankenhaus explodiert
diese müssen von innerhalb der stadt
abgefeuert worden seien
von wem ist unmöglich zu sagen
die schützen
wir haben alle in den keller gebracht
hier im keller ist der schuldige aber
bald gefunden
[Musik]
wir alle fordern dich auf stoffe diesen
krieg wieso bringst du deine eigenen
leute hier um wir waren einmal alle
brüder und schwestern fürchtegott vor
schwenkow soll es diesen poroschenko so
zerfetzen wir unsere kinder hier
dreckskerl und so einer nennt sich vater
des volkes
anastasia und ihr sohn mit jahr mussten
den ganzen tag daheim bleiben büro und
kindergarten blieben aus
sicherheitsgründen geschlossen
die gelernte designerin arbeitet jetzt
für eine aktivistengruppe der
pro-russischen separatisten sie
organisiert unter anderem humanitäre
hilfe und soll das neue logo die
aktivisten entwerfen
als basis wollten sie die fahne der
neuen republik donets dann habe ich mir
gedacht welches symbol soll ich für
unsere aktivistengruppe wählen die faust
in der luft oder so ich habe mich dann
für hände entschieden die sich reichen
und zusammenarbeiten im fußballstadion
von donetsk fanden 2012 spiele der
europameisterschaft statt jetzt werden
hier lebensmittel an tausende von
bedürftigen verteilt gespendet vom
lokalen oligarchen und stadion besitzer
die regierung in kiew schickt keine
sozial gelder mehr weder renten noch
löhne
einen tag später fahren wir mit
anastasia nochmals in die gebiete nahe
des flughafens
jetzt schießen sie wieder zurück auch
anastasias haus ist beschädigt worden
eine rakete schlug ins dach ein eine
nachbarin kam ums leben
sie will eine andere nachbarin besuchen
die invalid ist das ist der letzte
buchweizen den wir haben wir haben kein
geld mehr nichts
jetzt zahlen sie auch unserem sohn lohn
nicht mehr
ich habe keine verwandten mehr weil der
nicht sonst wohnen könnte sie habe
informationen sagte uns anastasia wonach
angeblich alleine im dezember internets
mehr als zwei dutzend menschen
verhungert sein
etwas abseits der kamera zeigt sie uns
wo die raketenwerfer der separatisten
stehen mitten im wohngebiet und über
noch etwas spricht sie mit uns über die
angebliche anwesenheit von sogenannt
dritten kräften gruppen die beide
konfliktparteien angreifen würden ja es
soll hier solche gruppierungen geben ich
habe davon gelesen aber habe keine
ahnung wer das sein könnte
das heißt diese würden sowohl die
position der ukraine als auch diejenigen
der separatisten beschießen sind wir
noch am gleichen tag zufällig zeugin
einer solchen tat geworden
in einem bisher sicheren stadtteil
explodieren mehrere minen geschosse
neben einem bus über ein dutzend
menschen sterben die ukrainischen
artillerie positionen können es nicht
gewesen sein
die sind zu weit weg dennoch machen die
russischen fernsehsender und vorzüglich
die ukraine für den anschlag
verantwortlich
die separatisten zerren ukrainische
gefangene an den unglücksort zur
aufhetzung der bevölkerung
das geschieht regelmäßig verstößt aber
gegen die genfer konventionen der
ukrainische geheimdienst berichtet von
russischen sondereinsatz gruppen die
internetkauf hohen gebäude schießen
sollte
aussage gegen aussage einmal mehr
ich frage mich gibt es kräfte die ein
interesse daran haben ukraine gegen
ukraine aufzusetzen
für mich heißt korrespondenten war es
kein leichtes jahr
gerne hätte ich über fortschritt und
eine bessere zukunft für die ukraine
berichtet doch unvermittelt wurde ich
zeuge der gräben die sich zwischen einst
befreundeten völkern öffnen können in
einem krieg der niemals hätte beginnen
dürfen
[Musik]
die zwillingsbrüder oleg und alexei
inzwischen beide mit bart bei der
beerdigung eines kameraden den sieht das
heißt der ruhige nannten alexy erzählt
in der grabrede das tier durch seinen
einsatz mehreren kameraden das leben
gerettet habe so entstehen neue legenden
und hätten allerdings nur für einen teil
des landes
[Musik]
den kampf im donbass wollen die
zwillinge bis zum schluss fortsetzen
sie sind überzeugt dass sie hier nicht
gegen ukrainische mitbürger kämpfen
sondern gegen die russische armee
nochmal eine salve es war diesmal wohl
an der rakete
diese don was ist eigentlich eine große
last auf den schultern der ukraine
eigentlich hätte ich schon lange gesagt
sollen sie doch hier leben wie sie
wollen
aber was mich daran hindert ich weiß
genau dass putin dieser dreckskerl keine
ruhe geben wird und immer mehr will mehr
territorium mehr einfluss und mehr
rechte für sich dem ganzen müssen wir
hier ein ende setzen
[Musik]
in donetsk durchziehen tiefe risse nicht
nur die fassaden die häuser ein nachbar
aus diesem haus kämpft in der
ukrainischen armee
er hat gesagt ich habe den eid auf die
ukraine geleistet und werde diesen
einhalten
wir haben gefragt wirst du auch auf uns
schießen und er sagte wenn es sein muss
werde ich das ich kann ihn zwar als
soldat verstehen aber ihm als mensch
werde ich nie verzeihen können vladimir
der bauarbeiter hat inzwischen donetsk
verlassen
er will zu seiner familie außerhalb des
konflikt gebietes warten bis der
alptraum vorbei ist
die situation ist mir zu angespannt die
sollen endlich eine lösung finden ohne
krieg das einundzwanzigste jahrhundert
und die wollen immer noch alles mit
gewalt entscheiden
[Musik]
[Applaus]